Okay. Good afternoon, everybody.
Thank you so much for joining us in this
educational session called "When Tumors Act Like Viruses: Mechanisms and
Therapeutic Frontiers."
So in this session, we are going to provide a general overview
of molecular mechanisms
that explain the viral mimicry response in cancer, with a focus on the
epigenetic mechanisms regulating this process and,
in addition, the impact on the tumor microenvironment.
We will
explore a few targets that are able to induce this
viral mimicry response in cancer and the effects on
antitumor immunity and a potential role in enhancing
responses to
immunotherapy.
So our speakers today will be
Dr. Catherine Chapinelli,
associate professor at the George Washington University in Washington,
D.C.,
and Dr.
Nicolas Babret, an assistant professor at Icahn School of
Medicine at Mount Sinai,
and myself. My name is Israel Cañadas, and I'm an assistant professor
at Fox Chase Cancer Center.
So I will be the first speaker.
Okay.
And I'm going to talk today about
how to turn a cold tumor hot and using viral mimicry as a
therapeutic strategy in cancer.
So I would like to start with a brief introduction of the concept
of cold and hot tumors. As many of you will already know,
cold tumors are these tumors that show a low immune infiltration,
in other words, no presence of immune cells or very low presence of immune cells.
And on the other hand, we have the hot tumors that are these tumors with
high immune infiltration, presence of immune cells inside the tumors.
Generally speaking,
hot tumors or tumors with high presence of immune cells, in general, they
show a better response to T cell checkpoint inhibition or other
immunotherapy
strategies. That's why there's a very
high interest in the field about how we can turn this cold tumor
hot.
And one
way to do that is enhancing innate immunity in
cancer, right? So because if we are able to induce an innate immune response in
the tumor microenvironment, this can be a way to
turn this cold tumor hot. And already there are
multiple current clinical trials of drugs that are
targeting the innate immunity, highlighting the importance and the
interest on these approaches.
So already in the 20th century,
there were some already indications trying
this, specifically if we see what is called Coley's
toxins. This was Dr. Coley's, that he already tried
something like that. He injected bacteria
into patients with cancer,
basically with the purpose of inducing an immune response in the tumor
microenvironment. And actually, the response was
quite dramatic in some patients. However, and obviously also at the
same time, were really big problems with infections,
as you can imagine. But this was like a proof
of concept that an immune response in the tumor can
actually have an antitumor
response.
But then at this time was not yet
discovered this concept of the viral mimicry response, and I would like to
introduce these two studies that were the first time when
really in the cancer field, we talk about this viral mimicry.
So
these were two studies where
inhibition of DNA methylation was inducing an immune response,
and the mechanism was through the reactivation
of endogenous retroviruses, that at the same time, they were
generating double-strand RNA, these cytosolic nucleases
that were triggering an innate immune response
and enhancing responses to immunotherapy.
So what is viral mimicry? It's the activation of innate
immune signaling pathways in cancer
cells driven by the aberrant accumulation of cytoplasmic
nucleases. So where these cytosolic
nucleases are coming from? Because they are endogenous
cytosolic nucleases. Basically, from the reactivation of silenced
transposable elements, including lines, signs, and
endogenous retroviruses.
These transposable elements, they are recognized by
cytosolic pattern recognition receptors
that can include RIG-I-like receptors, like
MDA5 or RIG-I, or toll-like receptors, like
TLR3 or others, that they can recognize double-strand
RNA, but also the cGAS-STING pathway that can recognize
double-strand DNA.
So downstream effects of this response
basically involve an interferon response and the induction of
MHC class I, which can clearly make these tumor cells more
immunogenic. And as you can imagine, this has a big
therapeutic relevance.
Multiple epigenetic therapies, including DNMT, EHZ2,
LSD1, et cetera,
CDK inhibitors,
all these different therapeutic relevant, clinically relevant drugs are able
to induce this viral mimicry, and there's a clear impact on the
tumor microenvironment and the immunotherapy
response.So there are different
histone targets that can induce the viral mimicry, including
histone methyltransferases, the methylases, or the
acetylases. But also there are other non-histone targets,
including cyclin-dependent kinases, spliceosome target therapies,
DNA/RNA helicases, and also dsRNA or dsDNA
negative regulators like ADAR or TREX1.
So I would like also to briefly introduce this
paradox that I find that is quite interesting
because a chronic viral mimicry can also induce immune evasion.
So far I was explaining how this viral mimicry can have a big impact
in inducing innate immunity, right?
But recently this study show how actually
chronic viral mimicry can also induce
immune evasion. So how this is happening,
for example, the example reported in that
study was through the p53 loss, very common in a lot of
cancers. So this p53 loss is inducing a transcription
of immunogenic repetitive elements that this is going to
induce a viral mimicry response that actually can
control the growth of early cancer
cells. So after this viral mimicry becomes chronic
through the constant activation of this immune response through immunogenic
repetitive elements, some
cancer cells can actually tolerate these cytosolic
nucleases and some of these clones actually can reduce
immunogenicity, and in that way they can promote immune
evasion. At the same time, this understanding the mechanisms
that can
induce this
tolerance to cytosolic nucleases can open new windows of therapeutic
opportunity.
So,
the viral mimicry can also be induced in lung
cancer, and this is some of our previous work in which
in specific populations of small cell lung cancer
cells, we were able to see that they spontaneously were more
immunogenic than isogenic parental cells.
So we found actually that these cells were in an
epigenetic state allowing the reactivation of some of these endogenous
retroviruses, that we call them SPARCs, and generating
this double-strand RNA that can trigger an innate immune response.
So we observed that actually these ERVs
were correlated with antigen presentation, EMT,
immune evasion, but also associated to some epigenetics
factors or chromatin modifiers related with this epigenetic
state.
So,
then we are using this concept trying to
turn cold small cell lung cancers tumor hot.
Small cell lung cancer is a clear example of a cold tumor,
very low immune infiltration and really aggressive and
difficult to treat tumor. So then we think that inducing an immune
response in the tumor microenvironment of these tumors can
be an effective way to make them more sensitive to different kind of
therapies. So far we have identified a
few targets that are able to induce that in this context,
including RNA helicase DSH9,
deoxynuclease TREX1, or the spliceosome.
Inhibiting these different factors that they are
viral mimicry
inducers, we can actually induce the accumulation of different
nucleases, including dsRNA, dsDNA, R-loops,
but also less common forms of dsRNA like zeRNA.
And this, at the end of the day, will induce this interferon response,
DNA damage, cytokines, tissue presentation, and the viral
immune response, which will make these tumors more
immunogenic.
So,
we were very interested in identifying targets to induce
this dsRNA accumulation in cancer cells.
So using small cell lung cancer as a model, we perform a CRISPR screen of
RNA helicases and measure dsRNA
accumulation. And in that way, it was how we
identify DSH9 being one of the targets inducing
higher accumulation of double-strand RNA.
And actually, interestingly, DSH9 expression
was
quite high, specifically in small cell lung cancer.
So as I mentioned, we were able to see after DSH9 depletion,
this accumulation of double-strand RNA,
dsRNA. And after sequencing this dsRNA and performing
RIP-seq, actually, we found that it was enriched in different
retroelements, including SINEs, LINEs or LTRs.
Interestingly, we also observed that the deletion of DSH9
can also induce the accumulation of DNA-RNA hybrids in
the cells.
After RNA sequencing of these cells, we were able to see that actually a
clear immune response, but also DNA damage was
triggered after DSH9 knockout, and this was related with the accumulation
of the dsRNA, but also DNA damage derived from this
DNA-RNA hybrids induction.
We found that this response, this interferon
signaling, was dependent on
both STING and MABS. After knocking out
STING and MABS, we were able to rescue the induction, for example, here of
interferon beta induced by DSH9 knockdown,
and also some clear markers of innate immunity like for TBK1 or
for IR3. After both sensors were
deleted, we were not able to see this phosphorylation
of TBK1 or IR3, very common after an innate immune
activation.We wanted to translate that
to in vivo, and then we took
advantage of our small cell lung cancer mouse model.
We inoculated, in an immunocompetent model, mouse's small cell lung
cancer cells, and we
induced the knockdown of DSH9. And this
significantly decreased the tumor growth, and also was
correlated with an increase in CD8 T cells.
This motivated us to repeat same experiment, but in that case, also treating
with
anti-PD-1. And actually, the combination of anti-PD-1 with
the deletion of DSH9 dramatically improved the
response to immunotherapy, but also their survival.
So
the dsRNA has been clearly showed to induce this viral mimicry
response. But we were also interested in less common forms of
dsRNA,
like for example, crRNA, that this is a left-handed
orientation of the regular dsRNA that is called a RNA, that has
been,
in the last year, show that actually can induce viral mimicry
through CBP1-dependent necroptosis
after viral infection, but also in some
cancer models. So inspired by
this work and others where spliceosome inhibitors were
inducing viral mimicry through the accumulation of double-stranded RNA, we
check if actually spliceosome inhibitors were able to also
induce an accumulation of crRNA, and it was like that.
In different mouse and human small cell lung cancer cell lines, we clearly
observed this increase in crRNAs.
And after
pull down the crRNAs and sequencing them, or in other words, after doing
RIP-seq, we were able to see actually, after
SF3B1 inhibition with this pladinolide B, or PlB,
a clear shift, an accumulation of an
induction of intron retention. So when we
check these genes with intron retentions, actually they were clearly
enriched in cells treated with this SF3B1
inhibitor. And we also observed that some of the
genes were enriched with the presence of,
in that case, science elements with the potential capacity of generating
these secondary structures that can trigger an immune response.
So
this crRNA can be sensed by CBP1, and it will trigger this
RIPK3/MLKL-dependent necroptosis, that is an
immunogenic cell death. And we actually
observed that this necroptosis was dependent on
CBP1 after cells were treated with this
spliceosome inhibitor. This FOSL/MLKL activation
also indicate necroptosis after the treatment with a spliceosome inhibitor
was only observed in cells overexpressing CBP1, but not in cells
with no expression of CBP1. And also
the mutation of one important domain necessary for the
detection of crRNAs, this C alpha domain, when we mutated that,
we were able also to rescue this decrease in cell viability, indicating one
more time that CBP1 was necessary for the cell death observed
after spliceosome inhibition.
So we translated these results to in vivo
using this small cell lung cancer model.
Again, we inoculated subcutaneously
these mouse's small cell lung cancer cells in immunocompetent mice.
We treat with this
spliceosome inhibitor,
and then we checked tumor growth that was
decreased compared with
DMSO control cells, and also the survival was increased.
Interestingly, we were able to observe
increase of presence of fibroblasts in the tumor
microenvironment,
that actually were expressing this FOSL/MLKL, suggesting
that this spliceosome inhibitor was inducing necroptosis also
in fibroblasts from the tumor microenvironment, also
quantified here.
We performed the same experiment but treating with
PD-1 blockade in the combination with a spliceosome inhibitor.
First, in wild type
mice,
thus they express CBP1, we were able to see that the
combination of both treatments slightly improve
the
response and with this decrease in tumor growth.
But what was very important and interesting for us is that
when we repeat exactly same experiment in CBP1 knockout
mice, actually, we were able to completely rescue the response
to the spliceosome inhibitor, but also to the combination,
suggesting that the CBP1 expression in the host was
necessary to see this response to
the spliceosome inhibitor and the combination with anti-PD-1.
So, this is a summary in which basically we found
that these spliceosome-targeted therapies can induce necroptosis
not only in tumor cells, but also in some cells from the tumor microenvironment,
like fibroblasts,
inducing this crRNA, CBP1-driven necroptosis, and this
can be a way to
turn this cold tumor hot and improve the immunotherapy response.
Finally, I would like also to show an example of
how viral mimicry can be also important in chemotherapy resistance,
and this target that we identified,
TREX1, as a potential inducer of the viral mimicry
response. As you may know, the chemotherapy treatment
can induce DNA damage that
can generate double-strand DNA and activate the cGAS-STING pathway.
So, using this small cell lung cancer model, in which we have some
cells that are resistant to chemotherapy, we perform
ATAC-seq, H3K27 acetylation
ChIP-seqAnd we're able to see a
significant increase of TREX1 expression only in these chemo-resistant
cells. This is HCT9-AR that are chemo-resistant derived cells.
By Western blot was very clear how only in these cells TREX1 was
induced.
TREX1 is the C-prime repair endonuclease one, and is a
negative regulator of the cGAS-STING pathway
since it's involved in the degradation of the dsDNA.
So, in collaboration with my former colleagues, Dr.
David Barbie and Dr. Navin Mahadevan, we were able to check the
expression of TREX1 across small cell lung cancer tumors pre- and
post-chemotherapy. And excitingly, we were able to see an
induction of TREX1 expression in post-chemotherapy
treated patients.
So we perform RNA-seq in the
small cell lung cancer cells after TREX1
knockdown, and we observe a clear induction of inflammatory
response and other
immune-related signatures, which was also
associated with an increase in phospho-IRF3
as an indication of an innate immune activation after TREX1
knockdown. We observed that actually these
results were
dependent on STING expression. After knocking down
STING by CRISPR, we observed that the knockdown of
TREX1 was not inducing anymore this phospho-IRF3 as we observe in
the control cells. And similarly, when we check
the expression of some interferon-related genes like interferon beta
or IFIT1, which were clearly induced
after TREX1 knockdown, this didn't happen or it
was significantly decreased after STING was also depleted.
We translated, sorry for here, I don't know what happened, but
basically, we translated these results
in vivo. In that case,
here we use a human small cell lung cancer cell line.
We injected subcutaneously, and in that case, we
depleted TREX1 in these cells, and then we
treated with chemotherapy with cisplatin.
And actually, we were able to observe that TREX1 knockdown
sensitized these cells that were quite resistant to cisplatin,
sensitized them to this chemotherapy treatment.
So in collaboration with my colleagues at Dana-Farber,
we were able to perform this assay in which we co-culture
these mouse small cell lung cancer cell lines
with an antigen-specific T-cells.
And we measure interleukin-2 as a
measure of T-cell activation or responsiveness.
Interestingly, when we knock out TREX1, we did
that in etoposide-resistant cells.
When we knock out TREX1 in these cells, actually, we were able to see
a clear, significant induction of their response,
indicating that TREX1 depletion is also increasing this TCR
responsiveness
in these cells.
So,
finally, as the title say, "When Tumors Act Like Viruses," basically,
I hope I convince you that actually it is possible
to make tumors act like viruses. And basically, with this
viral mimicry response in cancer, we can
induce this antiviral response derived from the accumulation of these
nucleosides that can be sensed
by different sensors that they were acquiring after
evolution, after fighting against virus during years
and years, and the sensing of these endogenous
nucleosides will induce this interferon
response that can help turn cold tumors
hot. So finally, very quick, thanks to all my
lab, especially Takahiko Murayama and Xinpei Jiang, the
main
responsables of this project.
All my collaborators, without them, it will be very difficult to do all of
this. And of course, all the funding agencies.
Thank you so much for your attention, and please let me know if you have any
questions.
Hi.
Yeah.
Great work. Thank you very much. I had a question for your SF3B1
inhibitor plus PD-1 data, and I wondered whether
if the viral mimicry is cell intrinsic, why were you expecting a PD-1
response? Have you looked at RNA splicing neopeptides or any
other contributors?
So we think that since the splicesome inhibitor is inducing
this necroptosis in the cancer cells, but also in some of the cells of the
tumor microenvironment.
And necroptosis is an immunogenic cell death.
So this is helping making the tumor more immunogenic.
And then,
what we think is that this can help to make this tumor response better to
different kinds of immunotherapies, in this case, immune checkpoint blockade.
But we think that also potentially others can also
increase the response after that.
Okay.
Thank you.
Good. Thank you.
Yeah?
Here. Really cool work.
Oh, yeah.
Yejing Ge from MD Anderson. It's really fascinating that you got all
those, cells got all those sensors for detecting different types of
nucleic acids. I'm curious,
in which kind of context you
would see more of Z form of RNA forming and sensing by
ZBP1, whereas in other kind of context, you have more of
double-strand RNA, be it A form.
I'm curious to hear your comments on this complex-
Mm-hmm.
-specificity issues.
Yeah.
Yeah, great question. So-And difficult to
answer because, for example, with the spliceosome inhibitor, we see also,
as you can imagine, dsRNA,
the most common form of dsRNA and at the same
time also crRNA. So we are not totally sure
in the case of the spliceosome inhibitor what is really controlling to
form
the most common form of double-stranded RNA or crRNAs.
We don't know. But what we know is that
it's possible to induce this necroptosis depending on CBP1, so
this means that the generation of the crRNAs are
significant. But
why in some cases will be more crRNA or more
RNA? I'm not sure about that, and I'm not sure if that's
known. But great question. Thank you.
Yeah.
Thank you. Really interesting. It's more a
comment that I am asking you. You induce a
very nice infiltration in the tumor and so,
but maybe you also induce more immunocheckpoints, and this
is the reason because your anti-PD-1, it works well.
Just a comment.
Yeah. No, that can be
totally possible. And actually, we see increasing PD-L1 expression, for example,
after a treatment with that. Something that now we are interested is also
to check that with cell therapies like CAR T
and all of that, if this viral mimicry can
also enhance these kind of cellular therapies.
Thank you.
Great work.
My question is regarding the actual
induction of viral mimicry in the
tissue infiltrating lymphocytes.
Does that help, or does that kind of initiate some
kind of constitutive immune surveillance or autoimmunity
eventually? So it's in the context of the
cancer, obviously, what happens in the immune cells.
Right. So yeah, in the case that
we tested, for example, with the spliceosome inhibitor, we were doing
intratumoral injection just to avoid potential
effects on all the immune cells of the body.
But yeah, definitely that's something that we are very interested how this,
for example, necroptosis or the viral mimicry in general, how can
affect the other immune cells from--
It's actually something that we are checking now in different contexts, and
hopefully soon I will have some answer for that.
Thank you.
Yeah.
It's a great talk. Actually, in the human small cell
lung carcinoma, the problem of the
immunotherapy is not only there's a cold tumor, but also
there's, as well, the cancer cells express very low levels of a
PD-L1 on the surface. So I just wonder,
depending on the model, then, as well, their
immune landscape is quite different.
Your model, this RPP model, then you also see there's
a low expression of a PD-L1 on cancer cell, or there
is actually some specific different type of that?
Yeah. The RPP model, and
I think it's low, the expression of both PD-L1 and
MHC class I in these cells are low. So
then we didn't check.
We check in vitro in these cells that after treating with some of these
targets that I just mentioned can induce expression, for example, of
MHC class I or PD-L1.
And actually, even though this immune
environment has become the hot immune environment, but if the
PD-L1 expression is low, then I just wonder how
anti-PD-1
effect can be increased.
Right. Because the viral mimicry, the idea is with the viral mimicry, we induce
expression of PD-L1.
So this immune response induced by these targets
that can make the tumor more immunogenic at the same time the cancer cells are
expressing this immune checkpoint locus trying to evade that.
But then that's the therapeutic window where we can treat with
anti-PD-1 because it's induced after the viral mimicry, because our
interferon induce genes, for example, PD-L1.
So have you checked there's a PD-L1 expression?
In vitro, yes. In the tumors, I don't think so we have checked it.
But in the in vitro, yes, it's induced by we have checked gene expression by qPCR,
yeah. But yeah, great question. Something we can check in the future.
Yeah. Thank you.
Thank you.
Hi.
I have a question about R-loops. So when you were doing the quantification using
the S9.6, have you ever considered doing other kind of measurements?
Because S9.6 can bind to dsRNA and
dsDNAs as well. Because in some
situations, there is a lot of induction of those, and it can
just be a false positive.
Yeah, totally agree. Yeah. Unfortunately,
it's not totally specific because it's difficult, right?
What we do so far is using RNase H
to make sure that these R-loops, so far, we are
using that antibodies, the tools we have
and yeah, overexpressing
RNase H to make sure that it is specific.
Yeah. And also dripseq is also a pretty good method to eliminate
those kind of stuff.
Yeah, we are working on that. We are doing dripseq, yeah.
Great. Thanks.
Thank you.
Hey, fantastic talk. Really great work.
So my question is more maybe outside of the realm of small cell
lung cancer, but any reason to think that there might be differences
in the viral mimicry landscape across
tumor types? Because there's a variety of sensors.
You've covered a great number of them, STING, cGAS,
ZBP1, but there's also AIM2 and all these other sensors and
in tumors, we're using thesebroad DNA
damaging, RNA damaging compounds that induce a variety
of nucleic acid-based damage. So do you think that the viral
mimicry landscape could be different across different tumor types?
Absolutely. Yeah, I think so. Because depends on the tumor type,
it's already known that there are some type of cancer that, for example,
can express high levels of ADAR, and this can-
Sure
... impact the viral mimic, right?
Or others can express TREX1 or others that can
down-regulate a lot of the, for example, factors of the necroptosis
machinery like CBP1, RIPK3. So
I think it's very context dependent, depends on the tumor
type. And I don't think probably the viral mimicry response will
work the same or even work in all tumors.
It will be specifically depending on which kind of cancer.
And with that, it's also related, this concept of this chronic
viral mimicry that can also induce kind of the opposite,
right?
Like a tolerance effect as well.
Right, the tolerance. So yeah. There's
still a lot to know about all of that and how we can approach therapeutically
different tumor types and different contexts. Yeah.
Fantastic. Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Okay.
If we have time for one more question.
Yeah. Of course.
I was wondering, what do you think drives protection in
your DHX9 knockout cells after treatment in
vivo? What pathway? Did you try to knock out STING or MAVS
to see that if you negate the effect?
Mm-hmm. Yeah. So in the DHX9, you mean, right?
In the DHX9?
Yeah, in vivo.
So it's a mix between the effects on
interferon response derived from the sensing of double-stranded RNA, but
also the effects of the RNA-DNA hybrids, because
these DNA-RNA hybrids are inducing replication stress, DNA
damage, and activating the cGAS-STING pathway.
Yeah.
So the combination of both is what we think that is
inducing this
immune response associated also to the DNA damage and cell death.
And at the end of the day, that's why we are seeing this decrease in
tumor growth, but also the potentiation of the PD-1, TP1
therapy.
Okay.
Okay. Thank you so much for the interesting questions, and now is
the turn of Dr. Katherine Chiappinelli. Thank you so much.
Good afternoon, everyone. Thank you for the invitation to present our work at this
educational session.
I'm going to focus on specifically epigenetic regulation of viral mimicry responses
in cancer.
So
when we think about treating cancer with epigenetic drugs, this was
first done in the context of reactivating tumor suppressors.
Just as tumor suppressor genes can be mutated to turn off their function, they
can also have epigenetic alterations.
One of which is DNA methylation, which is a covalent modification of the DNA
itself, which will have methyl binding domain proteins bind to it to compact the
chromatin. This can be reversed by DNMT inhibitors, including
AZA and DAC.
In addition, there are many modifications to the histone proteins themselves that
can be activating or repressive. One drug that is used in cancers are called
HDAC inhibitors, and these inhibit the enzymes that take off acetyl
groups. If you think about it, an acetyl group has a negative charge, and when it's
added to a positively charged histone, it pushes away the negatively charged
DNA, opening up the chromatin. So the original goal of both of these
kinds of cancer drugs was to turn on gene expression of silenced tumor
suppressors.
And as you've heard from the previous talk, another very important role of these
epigenetic drugs is actually through stimulation of innate immune signaling.
So we in the De Carvalho lab published back-to-back papers showing that DNMT
inhibitors remove DNA methylation across the genome, resulting in
transcription of transposable element RNAs.
These are sensed by proteins that would normally sense viral double-stranded RNA.
It's more of an RNA hairpin structure that activates these sensors,
resulting in type I interferon signaling and intrinsic cancer cell death, as
well as recruitment and activation of host immune cells.
Beyond DNA methylation, we and others have shown that HDAC inhibitors
can improve this response. HDAC inhibitors alone do not seem to be enough
to reactivate teRNA, but when you add HDAC inhibitors, this response is
increased.
Others have shown very nicely that when you inhibit histone methyltransferases, the
enzymes that add repressive marks to histones, you also see this induction of
teRNA and resulting type I interferon response.
Finally, cancers that harbor mutation in chromatin regulators
also exhibit TE upregulation baseline and this viral mimicry signature.
So I wanted to summarize about a decade of work here to show that when you
disrupt chromatin compaction in cancer, one of the biggest phenotypes is
transcription of RNA from transposable elements activating type I interferon
signaling.
And these transposable elements are about half of our genome.
They were discovered by Barbara McClintock, who won the Nobel Prize for this work,
and she discovered them in corn. So, when you think about a
transposable element, the simplest definition of it is a piece of DNA that can
move about the genome of its own accord.
So on this corn cob here, you can see yellow kernels and red
kernels, and then you can see a modeled kernel here, and that is the
result of a transposable element hopping into a gene that would encode, for
example, red or yellow pigment. And this is how she discovered this.
And in the human genome on the right here, this pie chart, we have about
half transposable elements. And I want to clarify that most of these cannot move
about the genome anymore. They have not been conserved through evolution.
However, they can make RNA and protein.
So you have about 8% endogenous retroviral or LTR elements,
remnants of old viruses that integrated into our genome.
These can make RNA and proteins, likely not particles, and they can likely not
retro transpose.
About 20% of the genome are line elements.
About 100 of these loci have the ability to retro
transpose.And then SINE elements or Alu elements, these
make RNAs in general, a lot of these immunogenic double-strand RNA species.
In healthy differentiated cells, most of these transposable elements are
silenced by chromatin modifications, including DNA methylation and
histone modifications. And during the global epigenetic dysregulation that
occurs when cells go from normal to cancer, a lot of them lose their
epigenetic silencing and are generally expressed at higher levels in cancers than
normal cells.
And as a result of this viral mimicry induction by epigenetic therapies,
we've shown that you can sensitize to immune therapy.
This is in a melanoma model where we're looking at the tumor growing.
This is untreated and then treated with anti CTLA-4 checkpoint blockade.
This is DNMT inhibitor alone, four doses, and the combination therapy is
better than either one alone.
In an aggressive model, a murines model of ovarian cancer, we're measuring survival
here. The black is untreated, and then the gray
is PD-1 alone, and then the orange is the combination of epigenetic therapy and
anti PD-1. And so just as was very nicely demonstrated in the previous talk, these
epigenetic drugs can also sensitize to immune checkpoint blockade in murines models
of cancer.
These have been translated to clinical trials, which I've tried to summarize here,
I think this is not all of them,
targeting multiple different kinds of tumors.
And really these results have been quite mixed,
where in ovarian cancer, there's not been a lot of responses, in lung
cancer as well.
But when you look at this melanoma trial, this was promising.
It's going to phase two. And I would say the most promising one recently was
this trial in NKT cell lymphoma, where patients that were refractory to
anti PD-1 were given DNMT inhibitors and then
became sensitive to this immune checkpoint blockade.
And so I think the spectrum of clinical trials shows that there's still a lot that
we don't know about how this works actually in the patients, and especially in
terms of resistance to this viral mimicry, which was discussed very nicely in the
previous talk.
So one thing that can drive resistance to viral mimicry is editing of these
immunogenic RNAs. So when you have transcription of these RNAs,
they are making these hairpin structures.
And Pari Mehtapoor and Daniel de Carvalho showed that these are edited by the ADAR1
enzyme. That's an A to I edit, which is read as a G.
And when you think about an RNA hairpin, it's going to relax the hairpin so that
it doesn't bind as well to MDA5 and activate immune signaling.
So my PhD student, Stephanie Gomez, wanted to understand how this affected
the tumor immune microenvironment.
And this is an aggressive murines model of ovarian cancer,
and if you look at the survival in the gray curve,
untreated, they're all dead by week nine.
You can increase survival with the DNMT inhibitor in red.
ADAR1 knockdown further increases survival, and the combination of both is much
better than either one alone. So in this case, inhibiting RNA editing plus DNA
methylation was much better.
And this was really due to reversal of the immune suppressive tumor
microenvironment, where you can see there's fewer M2-like macrophages,
fewer myeloid-derived suppressor cells, more M1-like macrophages,
and more natural killer cells. This is really consistent with a type one
interferon-driven change in the tumor microenvironment.
And to determine what was causing this,
Stephanie took our best surviving group, which is the solid purple line here, and
inhibited different parts of the response.
So when you inhibit type one interferon signaling, this is the dashed purple line,
it goes back to baseline. So type one interferon signaling is driving this whole
response in the immune competent mice.
When you inhibit natural killer cells in blue, it does not matter.
And when you inhibit CD8 T cells, there's a bit of an effect.
And indeed, we do see more proliferation of CD8 T cells in the spleens
of the combination group. And when we co-culture those T cells and
tumor cells, we do see more specific lysis of the tumor cells.
So in this case, the viral mimicry is causing type one interferon signaling that
brings in T cells to kill the tumor.
What we also observed was interestingly different responses to epigenetic therapy
in cell lines based on P53 mutant status.
So this was work done by my postdoc, James MacDonald.
And here we're looking at TEs upregulated by HDAC inhibitors, DNMT
inhibitors, or the combination of both, where the blue are the wild type cell lines
and the red are the mutant cell lines.
When you look at all TEs, there's a bit more upregulation in the wild type than the
mutant. But over here, when you look at these immunogenic SINE repeats, it's much
more dramatic.
And so we wanted to understand what's going on here.
So when we think about P53 mutations in cancer, there are plenty of null mutations,
but actually the most common mutations are in the DNA binding domain.
These alter P53's binding to its canonical targets.
You still will have P53 protein, but it's not going to be able to bind and activate
its canonical targets.
And when you look in the literature, P53 represses
transposable elements in flies and zebrafish.
John Abrams' lab has shown that P53 can bind directly to
line elements to suppress them. But Ting Wang
and Guillaume Burk have shown that P53 can bind to endogenous retroviruses and
upregulate them.
And finally, Andrey Gudkov's lab showed that fibroblasts from Li-Fraumeni
patients upregulate these TEs baseline and activate interferon signaling when
treated with DNMT inhibitors. So there was a lot of information in the literature,
both in terms of activation and repression.
And so we wanted to learn what P53 was doing in our
hands and started with wild type P53.
We use a drug called Nutlin to activate wild type P53.
This inhibits the interaction with MDM2, which normally leads to P53
degradation. And so you can see over here, it's stabilizing wild type
P53.
We looked for where P53 was going on the chromatin upon Nutlin
treatment, and you can see it binds to a lot of these SINE TEs, as well as LTRs and
lines, and at the individual locus level, lots of LTRs, as well
as SINES.
And we treat with AZO. We also see this binding to different TEs across the
genome. In terms of the transcriptional effects, Nutlin
increases transcription of TEs, so does the DNMT inhibitor,
and the combination of both is more than either one alone.
This is a volcano plot with the cutoff for significance here, and this would be an
increase or a decrease.So to put this together,
at least for LTRs in the genome, it looks like DNMT inhibitors remove
methylation, and wild-type p53 will go to these LTRs to
activate transcription.
As we were publishing this, Galina Slivonova's lab came out with really nice work
showing localization of p53 to IRVs upon nutlin treatment,
resulting in transcription of these and downstream interferon signaling.
So we can consolidate these data for this
model of how wild-type p53 works. However, most cancers do
not have wild-type p53. And so we wanted to learn more about how TEs are
regulated in the context of mutant and null p53.
To do this, we made an isogenic cell line model where we took our wild-type cell
line and edited it with CRISPR-Cas9 to make an R175H hotspot
mutant. You can see that this has high levels baseline, and then the null cell line
where there's no p53.
And this is work done by my PhD student, Trace Walker.
When we compare TE expression in the mutant versus wild type, we see
both upregulation and downregulation.
And we compare the null versus the wild type, there is a huge upregulation of TEs.
This is interesting.
To learn more about why these TEs are upregulated, we looked at expression of
regulators of DNA methylation. And so you can see in this null cell line, the
DNMT1 protein is much reduced compared to the others, and
UHRF1, which is an important protein that helps DNMT1 methylate the DNA,
is also much lower.
When we assess genome-wide DNA methylation with a dot blot, we also see that it is
lower in the null cell line. And double-stranded RNA, by the
J2 antibody, is much higher. So overall, p53 loss leads to
loss of DNA methylation across the genome and more immunogenic double-stranded RNA.
When we look at differentially methylated regions in this null compared to
wild type, we also see that a lot of these are going to be at the transposable
elements, including SINEs, LINEs, and LTRs.
There are plenty that do gain methylation, but more that lose it, and that there
really are
very few significant alterations in the mutant versus the wild type.
So this is really a phenotype of the null p53.
In addition, when we look at methylation versus expression, so here, these plots on
the X-axis going to the right will be increase in methylation, to the
left will be decrease. And then on the X-axis is the fold change.
So increase in expression, decrease in expression.
There's very few that are changed in this R175H versus wild type
compared to the null versus wild type, where many of these are losing methylation
and gaining expression, which would be loss of methylation leads to
upregulation, compared to other elements where there might be
methylation-independent re-expression.
For example, loss of p53 transcriptional silencing.
So knowing all of this, we then wanted to compare the response to DNMT
inhibitors in the
different p53 status. So for the wild type, we see that the DNMT
inhibitor upregulates lots of TEs.
These mostly lose methylation and gain expression as we would expect.
The R175H mutant is much less responsive, which is very interesting,
potentially due to the lack of this hotspot mutant binding at the
LTRs where the wild-type p53
binds.
And then the null has a much bigger response.
There's a much bigger upregulation upon DNMT inhibitor. You can see this over here.
Lots of TEs are losing methylation and gaining expression.
And indeed, these p53 null cells are the most responsive to DNMT inhibitor.
So this is a bubble plot where red is a higher fold change, blue
is lower, and then the size
is correlated with significance.
The first column is wild type, AZA treated, then R175H, then
null. And you can see that the interferon-stimulated genes are highest in the null
cell line when they're treated with AZA.
And my student has a poster on Tuesday afternoon on this work.
Please go and talk to him about it because it's really interesting, and I think we
still have a lot of questions in terms of how the signaling is working.
But I also wanted to bring up this idea of chronic TE expression interferon
resistance. So this paper from Charles Ischek and colleagues.
In terms of this, we do see the highest upregulation of TEs in
interferon in the p53 null cells, but this could eventually be bad.
Where we contributed a little bit to this paper with an immune
competent model of ovarian cancer, where we compared p53 wild
type to null treatment with AZA. And so in the wild type, the light
blue here, treatment with AZA does seem to work better than the p53
null in green treatment with AZA. And so I do think we have to think about the idea
of chronic viral mimicry interferon and eventual resistance.
And this will change how these are being translated to the clinic.
So we can put this together. I tried to pull different published papers in terms
of how p53 regulates human TEs specifically, where on the left side we have
LTRs where wild-type p53 generally upregulates these.
DNA methylation silences them. While there's more evidence for wild-type p53
repressing LINEs, and DNA methylation silences these, too.
Beyond this, we do see that p53 loss reduces DNA methylation
genome-wide, amplifying the effects of DNMT inhibitors.
In addition, this hotspot mutant R175H alters TE transcription,
but not via DNA methylation.
So we need to figure out more about how this p53 is
affecting DNMTs genome-wide, and thus DNA methylation.
Okay. So finally, I wanted to present a few slides on
analysis of patient data. So of course, with all of this in cell lines and mouse
models,
in general, we're going from TE induction to interferon to infiltration of
immune cells. We wanted to analyze data from patients to see if this was occurring
baseline in the patients as well. And we were very fortunate to work with Dale
Garsed and David Bowtell, who have a consortium that is led by Dr.
Pearce looking at high-grade serous ovarian cancer patients.
And so,
this is a disease where the standard of care is surgery followed by
chemotherapy. And unfortunately, most patients do become resistant and their
disease recurs.And so this consortium has a group
of long-term survivors, which would be over 10 years for this disease, moderate
term, which is two to 10 years, and short-term, which is less than two years.
And they've already published that these long-term survivors are characterized by
deficiencies in homologous recombination as well as more infiltration of B
and T cells, which makes a lot of sense.
And we, of course, were curious about transposable element expression in these
long-term survivors. And so this is unpublished work led by my student, Kevin
Nestler. He compared TE expression in the long-term
survivors versus the short-term survivors, and we do see increased TE expression in
general here. This is a volcano plot.
Just to pull some out, LTR-12C, which is often upregulated by DNMT
inhibitors, is much higher in the long-term survivors in maroon, as is
LTR-25.
When we look at the locus-specific level, we do see upregulation of line one and
LTR elements. You can see line one full length here is really increased in the
long-term survivors. And I wanted to point out HERV-W, which is
all the way up here. This is actually an ERV that encodes an
immunosuppressive protein that can be expressed on the surface of cells, and it's
downregulated in the long-term survivors, which is quite interesting.
So after seeing these results, Kevin decided to do unsupervised
clustering of the patient samples based on TE expression.
And so here on the left, we're looking at lines, LTRs, and SINEs.
So there's a high-expressing group here,
there's a low-expressing group, C2 in the middle, and there's a medium-expressing
group on the right, and each column here is a patient.
So when we look at the survival of these groups, the cluster C1 in
teal that has the highest TE expression has significantly longer
overall survival as well as progression-free survival.
We wanted to know if there were molecular features that explained this upregulation
of TEs and potentially longer survival.
This is a busy slide, but the short answer is no.
So you can see the high TE, low, and moderate TE groups here.
There were no significant differences on age, smoking status, HRD status,
P53, or BRCA. And I want to make a note about P53.
Basically, all of these patients have P53 mutations, so we have no wild type to
compare to, unfortunately,
because of the disease.
So there was no specific genetic alteration that associated with this.
If we look at epigenetic regulators, there also were not clear ones that stood out
except for KAT2A. This is a histone acetyltransferase that was higher
expressed in the C1 group, and so we're looking into this further.
Finally, we do see a small change in methylation at these inverted-repeat Alus.
So again, these inverted-repeat Alu elements can make these hairpins that are
sensed by MDA5, activating type I interferon response.
This is DNA methylation analysis of methylation array data, where
zero is no methylation, one is 100% methylation, and the
density on the y-axis is how many elements are you adding up that have zero or
100. So you can see a lot of these IR Alus are 90% methylated.
And if you compare C2 and C3 to C1 in the teal here, there is a little
bit less methylation there.
So finally, we want to know if these patients had increased immune cell
infiltration. And first, we used CytoSort to
estimate the percentage of immune cells in these samples.
And in general, there are more B cells in the C1 cluster.
There's more follicular helper T cells, fewer neutrophils, and fewer
macrophages.
We were fortunate to have access to multiplex IHC on a subset of these samples, and
this really confirms a lot of the data from the
CytoSort, where there's more PD-1 positive immune cells and
CD8 positive T cells and B cells. So this is really going along with more
infiltrating lymphocytes.
In terms of what can be upregulating this innate immune response,
besides the IR Alus, full-length line ones that are reverse
transcribing can activate cGAS-STING signaling with DNA-RNA
hybrids. This was published by Marty Taylor and colleagues to activate type I
interferon. And when Kevin looks at the expression of these full-length lines, they
are increased in the C1 group.
When we look at the IR Alu elements that can also activate this response, these
were also increased, so we could not narrow it down to one or the other.
And then finally, because type I interferon is induced by this signaling, we wanted
to measure type I interferon expression.
And interferon alpha, in this case, is significantly increased.
So in summary, the samples with high TE expression have longer survival, higher
levels of PD-1 positive immune cells, T and B cells,
and express potentially immunogenic TEs.
And current work is determining how this is really being regulated in these
patients baseline.
So overall, we've talked about epigenetic therapies that open the chromatin to
activate type I interferon through transposable element RNA.
Wild type P53 transcriptionally regulates TEs.
Mutations in this gene alter the viral mimicry response in cancer, which may have
important therapeutic implications.
And then when we have high TE expression in these ovarian cancer patients, this
correlates with increased T and B cell infiltration, type I interferon, and longer
survival.
And so finally,
I was fortunate to work with Cathy Burns to write a review on transposable elements
in cancer for "Cancer Discovery," where we describe how
transposable elements contribute to six of the defined hallmarks of cancer.
And the "Cancer Discovery" team asked me to include this here because apparently
it's being published now, so you can see it.
And we proposed this as a new hallmark of cancer, actually.
So this is for you all to peruse if you're interested in learning more about
transposable elements in cancer.
Okay.
And so I want to thank everyone on my team who did the work, as well as our funding
and many collaborators who I've already mentioned.
And thank you for your attention. I'm happy to take any questions.
Hi. Wonderful talk. I have two questions.
My first question is,
P53 has so many targets and so many binding elements,
so your discovery of specific regulation of lines and SINEs,
could it be an indirect effect, and does it also impinge on
other loci?
Absolutely. So I think that there are both direct and indirect effects.
We physically tried to separate out which ones we see wild-type P53 actually
binding to in terms of the ones that are being transcribed.
But we also see alteration in transcription of elements where P53 is
not binding directly. So for example, on the P53 null,
the TEs that are upregulated are not a lot of the ones where it's binding directly.
So I think that's more of a result of DNA methylation loss.
And so that's why we have these data.
We're now actually combining H3K9 methylation, H3K4
methylation cut and run to see how the chromatin is being altered.
But yes, that is why P53 is really hard to work with.
Yeah.
And we also tried to use NETland rather than DNA damaging to avoid the DNA damage
response. Yeah.
My second question is more specific.
So the data you showed that all of your
high-grade serous ovarian cancer patients had P53 mutation, that is expected.
But did you try to classify the mutations, maybe
hotspot versus non-hotspot? Does it segregate your
long-term and short survivors?
Yeah, that's a great question. We're doing that right now, of trying to classify
them into
how... At least we can do null versus hotspot, and then even
the going by mutation didn't work because there were only
five of each mutation, right? There weren't that many of each mutation, but we
could at least do null versus hotspot. Yeah.
Yeah. Thank you.
Thank you.
So, very nice talk. Two questions.
First is actually follow-up on that and translating this
into a clinical trial.
You probably want to enrich for patients who have the appropriate
P53 alteration. And in that regard, how
much work has been done with Li-Fraumeni, where that's
the sine qua non, right? Where you have
no P53, it is the genesis of their cancers.
And to me, that would seem like the purest model to
really dissect
these elements and to really understand the operating
characteristics before you embark on
studies to see if you can enhance immune response.
Absolutely. Yeah. There's that one paper on it, right?
From 2009, in terms of the Li-Fraumeni fibroblasts that
then have a big upregulation when treated with DNMTi. It's a really good point.
I think that would be a great thing to start with in terms of
this upregulation, then differences in the different patients.
So you are aware that there's a very large Li-Fraumeni cohort
that's being followed at the NIH?
Mm-hmm.
So something to look-
Yeah, that'd be great.
Yeah.
Yeah. Thank you.
It's a fantastic talk. I'm quite interested in the
tolerogenic resistance that can be induced by TEs,
and
I guess I have two questions. I'll start off with, I guess, the easier question
first. You showed us data on
the genomic landscape and how that could be associated with these different TE
classes, the abundances. But it seems like you have RNA sequencing data
as well. Did you look there to see if there are certain pathways that
are activated and perhaps associated with the
abundances of transposable elements that-
Sure. This is baseline or upon DNMTi treatment or?
At baseline.
At baseline. In the different
patients, or is this in cell lines? Sorry, just to clarify.
In patients.
Oh, in the patients. We're mostly seeing type I interferon signaling, to be
honest.
Okay.
I'm trying to think of if we saw other things that were differently
enriched, but no, it's mostly... And then, again, looking at the epigenetic
regulators, there was one that stood out, so we're investigating that one further.
Okay, excellent. Yeah, and my second question
was related to the tolerogenic state.
Coming from a triple-negative breast cancer sort of environment where inflammation
is quite common,
what resistance pathways do you think are terminal that are maybe
responsible for poor outcomes as a result of this tolerogenic
state?
Sure.
So one example that I thought was really clever was
Andiman, that had work where they showed
this kind of chronic acute type I interferon, and this can have negative effects
on T cells, et cetera. So when they inhibited JAK-STAT
signaling, both in mice and in
cell lines,
this was resolved and actually increased sensitivity
or really reversed this and increased sensitivity to immune checkpoint blockade,
and then a clinical trial that they did did the same thing, right?
So I think we need to think broadly about in which
context is adding an epigenetic therapy or something to target
DHX9 going to work
in an acute way to bring in the immune cells to fight the tumor, and in which
context are you going to have perhaps P53 null cells, right?
Are you going to have a lot of this kind of chronic viral
mimicry induction of eventually immune evasion?
But that's one thing that I've seen that can reverse it, right?
So that's the good example of it. Yeah.
Fantastic. Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Thank you very much. So I was wondering in the ovarian
cancer different clusters that you have, in the clusters where the TEs are highly
expressed, did you check if you have any splicing regulators that
are not expressed in the same way, like maybe crossing over to the first talk?
That is a great question. We have not, and we will do that. Thank you so much.
Yeah.
It's a really good suggestion. Yeah.
And I had a second question regarding all the clinical trials that have
been done on the viral mimicry.
Where it seems to work the best is in liquid tumors in AML,
and these are tumors where there have been reports that actually type I
interferon is actively repressed.
So do you think this is linked, or do you have any thoughts on that?
Thank you. Great question. I think it's two things.
So one is the first, where there's an AML, yes.
You have active repression of type I interferon.
The second, in terms of DNMT inhibitors, at least from the data that I've seen,
is drug delivery, where these have a short half-life, and when you're treating
AML, it's going right into the vein. Same with NKT cell lymphoma.
The delivery is much easier. In at least one of the trials on ovarian
cancer, they were able to take tumor biopsies and saw no
demethylation in the tumor. And so it was not getting there and viral mimicry was
not being induced. That's not to say that's happening in all of them, but I think
that it's two different things. So one that you mentioned of interferon being
dampened, as well as just liquid tumors being easier to treat with this type of
drug.
Okay. Thank you.
Quick question. Great talk. So I was glad to see all the
analysis in tumor samples. So I think that's very necessary in
the viral mimicry field. But I have a question about this analysis.
So because you show that the TE high tumors, they show a better
response, more infiltration, but this here can be also a context of
a chronic viral mimicry, right? So
I know it's complex, but any thoughts about that, how these
tumors with high TE without a treatment, I think
that
can be examples of a chronic viral mimicry response, how they are more
immunogenic and responding or having a better survival.
Right. We're really wrestling with this, right?
Because based on the idea of acute versus chronic, so this is exactly, these
patients haven't been treated with anything.
This is upon surgery, baseline, no treatment.
They have high TEs and high infiltration of lymphocytes.
So what is the series of events? We're only seeing a snapshot in time, and
so we can't do experiments on these samples, but we're trying to address
this by, there's a cohort of patients that we have access to the
primary tumor upon surgery, and then these patients recurred.
And so we have access to the recurrent tumors, and we're
doing comparisons there right now.
Because that's at least one way to say what comes back.
Is it different when it comes back?
Are there lower TEs or is it this high TE state that's generating immune
evasion? So I think that's, in patients, probably the only way we can answer that.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah.
Right. Thank you.
Kate, I have a question. So I think
when you compare TE expression across patient, the correlation with
survival is really striking. And I think it was very interesting to see that
you even saw ORF2 expression coming from LINE-1.
So I was wondering if you had access to DNA sequencing to see if in this patient
that survived longer, do we also have event of
jumping of a LINE-1 because they express the enzyme that allows them to
jump?
Yeah, great question. So yeah, this had more intact LINE-1, I guess, than we
expected, but ovarian cancer is a disease that expresses a lot of LINE-1s.
Mm-hmm.
So maybe it was to be expected. And we're doing that analysis right now.
Kevin's literally doing that right now, is looking at new LINE-1 insertions because
we have whole-genome sequencing-
You have the DNA? Okay, nice
... from these patients. We do not have batched blood, okay?
So we don't really have, but we can at least
try to estimate the new LINE-1 insertions in the tumor samples from these patients.
Yeah. Super nice.
Thank you.
Okay. Thank you.
Thanks so much.
And then our last speaker, Dr. Nicolas Verret from Mount Sinai.
All right.
Good afternoon, everyone, and thanks, Israel, for the opportunity to present my
work. So I will focus more specifically on the immune
response to viral mimicry in the TME in this work.
So
one important question that, or one challenge in the field
of immunotherapy is to try to understand how some
tumor, even when they express highly potent
antigen, they have high mutational burden, they
express strong antigen, they still remain cold.
So we have poor T cell infiltration, and
they resist to immunotherapy. And
one explanation that has been proposed is that
many of these tumors actually suppress innate immune sensing.
And so because they don't sense any
DAMP or a
molecular pattern that could activate the innate immune response in
the cells, they fail to mature antigen-presenting cell, like dendritic
cells, and this fail to also activate T cells
that are dysfunctioning.
And this kind of dysfunction really is not
observed during a viral infection because viruses are really good at
actually activating all this pathway of innate immune pathway that leads to
cytokine production and innate immune activation.
So I think the whole idea of what we're discussing today in this session is
therapeutically, if we can try to mimic a
state of viral infection in cancer cells by engaging this sensor that
has been initially described as viral sensor to induce a type one
interferon presentation, increase antigen presentation, and which
will lead to bringing unactivated T cells within the
TME and make cancer cell more easily recognized by these T
cells.
And so I will not describe too much the concept of viral
mimicry because Kate and Israel have done it
just before me, but just to mention that this is a
state of innate immune response that we can observe
naturally when there is a natural disruption of cellular
homeostasis. And this happen typically
during aging or actually during cancer development, when you have a
de-repression of epigenetic silencing of these transposable elements that are
reactivated and that are going to form this immunogenic structure that can activate
innate immune sensor like the double-stranded RNA that activate the
MDA5, MAVS pathway.
And fortunately for immunotherapy, we can reproduce or we can
push this
phenomenon by using these viral mimicry drugs,
which are largely this
epigenetic drug that are discovered by
work from, for example, Kate and Israel here.
So what are the actual pathway that are activated by
this immunogenic nucleic acid? So initially, it has been
described as the ability of this transposable element to form double-stranded RNA
that can activate MDA5 or TLR3 or RIG-I.
And I'm going to use the pointer. But I think the field is also trying
to recognize now that some of these transposable elements, because they can
express some reverse transcriptase, like the ORF2 from LINE-1 that we
were discussing,
could lead to the production of RNA-DNA hybrid, which is the
product of reverse transcription that can activate the cGAS-STING
pathway.And both
the
MAS pathway and the STING pathway are going to
activate this interferon regulatory factor and leads to the production of
type I interferon, but also an NF-kappa B pathway that is going to lead to the
production for pro-inflammatory cytokines.
And independently, as Israel mentioned,
you can also have a direct activation of cellular death pathway
through different receptors like PKR or RIPK1 and 3 or
ZBP1 that are going to activate death pathway
inside the cancer cell, so for example, apoptosis or necroptosis.
So what are the consequences of this activation on the TME?
So first,
one of the immediate consequences is that it's going to increase antigen
presentation by the cancer cell, because CLNS1 molecule or CLST molecule are
actually upregulated
in response to pro-inflammatory cytokines.
And so
you also have production of cytokines like CXCL10 or CCL5, is
going to promote immune cell infiltration,
and type I interferon, other inflammatory cytokines, are also going to be
able to directly activate
T cells and NK cells that are going to be better at recognizing cancer cells.
They are also going to
induce maturation and activation of dendritic cells that are going to promote the
cytotoxicity of CD8 T cells.
And
something that I study more in depth is also they promote the
macrophage polarization, so
are going to
change the profile of the macrophages in the tumor microenvironment that are
typically immunosuppressive to something that is going to be more immunoactive.
And something that is also being appreciated now is that some of
these transposable elements can also encode antigens, and these
antigens are not expressed at steady state.
And so their translation is going to lead to de
novo antigens that can
prime new T cells and further amplify the T cell response.
So how can we harness all these pathways therapeutically?
And
Kate mentioned this study, which was published
in December last year, and I just want to discuss a little bit
because
one of the things that
using viral mimicry is good at is really inducing this synergy with checkpoint
blockade. And one of the reasons, and we discussed some of the reasons earlier,
is first it increases antigen presentation by increasing MHC
expression, but also increases expression of checkpoint
ligands like PD-L1 that are upregulated in response to
pro-inflammatory cytokines. And in this study,
a
model of
NK anti-cell lymphoma, which is, as you can see, resistant to
checkpoint blockade. And when they treat these
mice with a DNMT inhibitor, decitabine, they do see a little
bit of reduction. But what really was striking is that the treatment with
decitabine
restores the sensitivity of the tumor to
checkpoint blockade on anti-PD-1.
And this was done in the context of a clinical trial of this patient
who had a refractory NK T-cell lymphoma.
And
what they observed is that this patient, who was resistant to anti-PD-1,
became sensitive to anti-PD-1 after using this DNMT
inhibitor that induces viral mimicry in the patients.
And this is one of the first
clinical evidence that activating the viral mimicry response
in humans can
induce a
therapeutic response.
All right. So
in my lab, we are specifically interested in cancer vaccination.
And one of the reasons is because with the
discovery of mRNA vaccine, there is a new momentum for cancer vaccination, which
has been illustrated by the result of a new clinical trial,
including this keynote clinical trial on a patient with
melanoma, when we saw that vaccinating them, the patient with
mRNA vaccine that encodes a personalized neoantigen, can
even improve the survival in addition to a checkpoint blockade.
But there are still a lot of challenges in cancer vaccination, and one of the
reasons
we are still failing to have strong responses is because we use this
vaccine in a therapeutic fashion.
And I like to illustrate that with one of the first experiments I did when I opened
my lab three years ago. We
developed an mRNA vaccine
that encodes a tumor-associated antigen
that are highly expressed in the model of
melanoma B16-F10. And so what we did is that we used
the vaccine in a prophylactic fashion.
So as you can see here, we first vaccinated mice,
and after, tried to engraft the B16 melanoma.
And this vaccine was very efficient at preventing
the engraftment of the
tumor, showing that it was not only good at
inducing T cell response, but this T cell response was able to prevent
engraftment to kill the tumor cells.
But now when we use the same vaccine in a therapeutic fashion, so exactly
the same dose, the same regimen, but the only thing that is
different is that we first engraft the tumor, and after, we vaccinate.
And as you can see here, when we did this experiment, the vaccine was completely
useless. It was not able to control the tumor, showing that it's one thing to have
T cells that are antigen specific and that are cancer specific, but you
need the T cell to actually be able to work within the tumor microenvironment.
And so what we think is that some of the limitations that are inherent to cancer
vaccine, notably the fact that when T cells come inside the tumor, they lose their
activity.Or, and they poorly actually infiltrate the tumor.
And even if they are in the tumor and they are functional, sometimes we cannot
recognize the cancer cell because the cancer cell does not
present its antigen
because of low expression. We think that some of the limitation inherent to cancer
vaccine can be actually solved if we induce a state of viral
mimicry inside the cancer cell.
And so to
test this hypothesis, the first thing is that we stay in our model of B16
melanoma, and we screen multiple drugs to identify the drug that
was best at inducing a viral mimicry response.
And perhaps not surprisingly, one of the drug that was the most efficient in our
screening was the DNMT inhibitor azacitidine.
And this is illustrated here when we perform RNA
sequencing on B16 that were treated with azacitidine, we show very
strong upregulation of transposable element across
different classes.
And when we specifically look at the transposable element that we predicted that
will be immunogenic, so the one that can form double-stranded RNA, for example, we
found that they were specifically enriched and transcribed by azacitidine.
And similarly, when we identify the transposable element that encode a reverse
transcriptase, so that can generate this RNA-DNA hybrid, we
found that azacitidine was upregulating a lot of them.
So
we use the same RNA-seq analysis to actually look at the type I
interferon response in the melanoma.
And what we found is that azacitidine induce a strong interferon
response that was calculated with the type I interferon score here.
And this interferon response was dependent on MAVS and
STING pathway, because when we use B16 lacking MAVS or STING, we have a
reduced interferon score, but no change in transposable element expression.
So which led us to conclude that azacitidine was
a drug with viral mimicry activity in B16.
So to test whether azacitidine could increase the cancer vaccine efficacy
in vivo, what we performed was an experiment when we first engraft
mice with tumor using the same vaccine we described before.
Then we vaccinate them, and then we shock the tumor.
So we try to improve the... We induce viral mimicry in the tumor using
azacitidine.
And what we found, and you can appreciate it here, is that every
treatment on its own, so azacitidine or vaccination
alone, were not able to control tumor.
But now when we combine both, we start to see some kind of tumor control and
improves survival of the mice.
So this was done on melanoma, but we wanted to
show that it could work in different system.
And so we generate mRNA vaccine
against new antigens that were found in different models.
So CD26, a colon carcinoma, that has MH2 knockout
system, so we generate frameshift antigen.
And so we generate a vaccine against this frameshift antigen.
Or a new antigen encoded in lymphoma.
We made a vaccine specific to this new antigen.
Or a tumor-associated antigen expressing in MC38, and we made a
vaccine against this tumor-associated antigen.
We also tried to do the same experiment, but using B16 as a
metastatic model, when
instead of engrafting subcutaneously, we inject the
pulmonary metastasis.
In all these different model, what you can see is that
azacitidine or vaccine on its own have very poor survival,
poor therapeutic efficacy. But now when we combine them, we can increase
the therapeutic efficacy.
We control that azacitidine in this different
cell line was actually inducing an interferon alpha or interferon
gamma response, which was the case.
And interestingly, when we look at actual, the expression of the antigen that were
encoding the vaccine, we found that azA did not change their
expression. So really,
we don't think that the effect that we observe is because we are
improving the antigen expression by the cancer cell, it's just like
the viral mimicry response.
So to try to better understand what was happening, we look at
expression of class I molecule inside the tumor, so in vivo, on
the
cancer cell fraction of the tumor, and we found that the combination increase class
I expression on the surface of the T cells or the cancer cells.
And we also found that
the combination vaccination increase the presence of
vaccine-specific T cells inside the tumor.
So now we observe,
understand why azacitidine was boosting vaccine efficacy, but we were not sure that
it was actually due to the contribution of viral mimicry, so the ability of
azacitidine to induce interferon response.
So to address this, what we did is that
we came back to the B16 melanoma model.
So here,
mice receiving vehicle control or the vaccine plus azA that control
the tumor growth.
But now we use cancer cells, B16, that are knockout.
Sorry, there's a mistake. That are knockout for MAVS and STING.
So they are not able to produce an interferon response in response to azacitidine.
But otherwise, the treatment is exactly the same.
And as you can see here, if we knock out MAVS and STING, the combination
therapy doesn't work anymore, showing that really it's the viral mimicry response
that governs the vaccination plus azA efficacy in this tumor model.
So to try to understand what was happening in the tumor response in the TME, we
perform single-cell analysis and
in the same group as here. So mice
bearing wild type or MAVS STING knockout tumor,
and
treated with vehicle control or the combination vaccination plus azacitidine.
And if we cluster on cancer cell, what we found is that only when the
mice receive the combination treatment and are able to produce a
viral mimicry, so they are engrafted with wild type B16,
we found this expression of interferon stimulated genes, showing that in vivo,
there is this viral mimicry response happening inside the cancer cell.And
interestingly, only in this condition we found a
downregulation of the vaccine target, TRP-1, NECTIN, and Pmel, which
indicate that there is an immune pressure against this target that
is
enabled by the viral mimicry, but we don't see this immune
pressure in mice that have
MAZ and STING knockout tumor, showing that
the viral mimicry response is important for this immune pressure.
And now when we cluster on myeloid cell, we found two striking
results. The first one was, there was an amplification of
CDC1s within the tumor that was also depending on the viral mimicry
response.
And there was a drastic reduction of the population of Arg1 positive
tumor-associated macrophages, which are these immunosuppressive
tumor-associated macrophages in the TME that express this immunosuppressive marker
like Arg1, VEGF, or SPP1. And this
population was depleted in the mice that received the
treatment and can produce viral mimicry, but not in the mice that received the
treatment and cannot produce viral mimicry.
And if we perform the bulk analysis on all the tumor-associated macrophages
in the TME, what we found is that
the combination treatment increase
immunosupprimarity marker like XXL9 and decrease the
SPP1 immunosuppressive marker, so confirming what
we found with a distinct population.
And finally, what we did was to look at the T cell compartment, and we found that
the combination therapy increase proliferation of the
CD8 T cells within the TME, which was a
good confirmation of what we found with TRP-1 positive
tetramer T cells.
And we performed TCR sequencing to study the clonality of these
T cells. And when we specifically try to
track the T cell clone that were shared between all
the mice group that received the vaccination, so
which are likely vaccine-specific T cell, we found that here in
green,
there was a proliferation of this clone within the TME only when you had
the viral mimicry response, but not when you didn't have the interferon response
from the cancer cell.
So in conclusion, what I hope I convince you is that if we induce a
viral mimicry state by azacitidine in V16
left untreated, but actually now in other model, we can improve the response to
therapeutic cancer vaccine. And this work by increasing antigen presentation,
by repolarizing myeloid cell population that are immunosuppressive to
something that is more immunoactive and support the immune response, and expanding
vaccine-induced T cells inside the TME.
So with a conclusion that viral mimicry treatment
is an effective strategy to improve cancer vaccine efficacy.
All right. I want to thank people that have been involved in this work, and
especially Ashley Ritkan, who was a PhD student in my lab, and Yuchen Shi, a
post-doc in my lab, and Laura, a PhD student in my lab, who we work
together for this work.
And our collaborator, especially the laboratory of Nina Bhardwaj at Mount
Sinai. And mention that if you are interested in this kind of work,
we have a post-doc position open in the lab. Thank you very much.
Thank you. Really interest. I have just a curiosity, which
is the rational to wait several weeks between
the
vaccination and then the viral mimicry induction?
Yeah.
Just to understand.
No, that's an excellent question.
So it's actually several days, because the tumor grows so fast that we cannot
afford to wait these days.
It's not weeks.
Yeah. And one of the reason, actually, I don't know if I can show other slide.
No, go ahead.
Well, so yeah. Well, perfectly. Exactly.
So, it's an important question. If we
induce viral,
as I said, during the priming, so we want really to
prime the immune response with vaccination, and it's kind of like a
prime pull strategy when we bring the T cell with the azacitidine treatment of the
cancer cell. And actually, if we do the treatment of vaccination
on azacitidine concurrently here in red, it doesn't work as
much.
Mm-hmm.
And I think that azacitidine can also impair the priming of the T cell during the
vaccination. So really, the consecutive part, which was the
initial hypothesis,
is important.
But days is okay. I thought about weeks and-
Yeah, no. Stay
... weeks really-
Yeah
... is a lot of time.
Really cool work. I was curious, it's very striking when
you had this double knockout tumor cells, and you got
really reprogrammed
the myeloid infiltration, right?
The CDC1 also got disappeared. I'm curious, how much do
you think it's contributed for so-called the inflammatory cell death,
that you really need that the tumors die dramatically for these
APCs to come in, and I'm curious about
all these concepts.
That's a good question. I think
immunogenic cell death here, we know that a lot of DAMP that can be released
during cell death could actually leads to this immunosuppressive
myeloid cell population. So I think here that what really matters is
the type one interferon response and not the immunogenic cell death, because I
would assume that we would see the opposite. Yeah.
Cool, thanks.
So with azacitidine, people always
think about the promise of epigenetic drugs
that what they do is really a stable
reprogramming event.
Mm-hmm.
So I'm wondering, have you looked in your model whether there
is any
You know, lasting
phenotypic changes. For example, the repolarization of the myeloid
compartment. Is that stable? Is that an induced
differentiation state, or does it go away when you take off the
drug?
So,
short question, the response is no, we haven't looked at-- We only look at a
one-time point in the tumor.
We don't think that the
repolarization of the macrophages is a direct effect of
azacitidine on the macrophages. Because if we use tumors that are
knockout for MAVS, we don't see this
repolarization. So we think that it's a secondary effect of type I interferon.
Whether this secondary
effect is lasting or not, we don't
know.
Can I?
Yeah.
Does this work? Sorry. It definitely works.
Yeah, I can just speak to that briefly in the tumor cells, where
in tumor cells, because we follow them out to 28 days or so, you see the
demethylation, and then it starts-- If you treat for three days, they're still
demethylated. At seven days, it starts to come back at 10 days.
But we do see type I interferon out to 28 days or so, which in the tumor cells,
if you just treat tumor cells. In the mice, if we stop treating with AZA, though,
we do see that the tumor responses go away.
So I think in an intact immune competent system, we have to treat it.
But we have the same data that in macrophages, that's more of a
result of type I interferon release and cytokine release, right, not directly on
the macrophages.
Hi. I think my question is about
how much do you think the
combination of ASA with a vaccine C effect is
contributed by interferon responses?
And I was thinking if you use type I interferon receptor knockout
mice, can you see those
effects in-
Yeah. So we haven't done type I interferon knockout
mouse. What we have done is we have done type I interferon knockout,
Ifnar knockout cancer cell, and we lose the
effect. So it's really type I interferon dependence.
Okay. And I have a follow-up. So do you think if you use
STING agonist to bypass the viral mimicry, can you achieve the same effect?
Yeah. At Monsana, we have a
lab that's really developing new STING agonist, and we want to
compare side by side, vaccine plus STING agonist versus vaccine plus azacitidine.
I think one of the important effects of azacitidine that will not
be reproduced by a lot of agonists is the fact that the type
I interferon is produced, or the activation is inside the cancer
cell and not the rest of-- If you put a cGAMP or a STING
agonist in the TMEs, it will probably be taken up by myeloid cells.
So you're going to activate the myeloid cells, but it doesn't mean that your cancer
cell is going to upregulate class one expression, that's going to do antigen
presentation. And I think one of the important things is really that you have
cancer cells themselves that are indirectly activated.
Whether it works better or
not as well, we will know because we're going to compare side by side.
It's something that we want to do.
Thank you.
Sorry if I missed it.
So
I just couldn't quite understand the model you chose
because they are pretty aggressive.
So let's say that the B16, you chose the metastatic
model.
Mm-hmm.
But clinically,
I believe there's a clinical trial used 5-Aza and
combined with immune checkpoint inhibitor.
My question is that why do you think vaccine will be combined
with the
5-Aza will be more potent effective
than combined with the ICI?
Checkpoint inhibitor. Yeah.
So do you know what I mean? Vaccine is a great idea.
Yeah.
Maybe it's at the early stage of the--
Just as a clinician, I think it's too late.
Yeah.
Maybe the vaccine will be much more effective at the early stage. Thank you.
So if we do Aza and checkpoint inhibitor, we rely on
endogenous T cell, right?
Mm-hmm.
So
this
would work or actually works in certain model if we have enough
endogenous T cells, and if
you don't need de novo priming from within the TME.
The advantage of combining with vaccination is really you make the
cancer T cells first, and azacitidine, you just use
it to get the T cell within the tumor and make the cancer cell more
recognized by the T cell. So you don't really care about
new priming,
which is different approaches. But I don't think there is
one better approach.
We just wanted to explore whether azacitidine would also work with the mRNA
vaccine.
Yeah, sure.
It's a great talk.
What are your thoughts on some of the work done by,
I think Elias Sayor and others on lipid
nanoparticles that can inherently generate this sort of type I
interferon response? I think there was a large paper published in
"Cell"-
Yeah.
-where they demonstrated that the nanoparticles by themselves
generate the type I interferon response.
No, I think it's important, and that's why when we control, generally our
control is an empty mRNA vaccine or with an
RNA that encode a non-relevant. So just to make sure that it's
not the innate immune activation by the mRNA itself or vaccine that plays a role
here.
And
what we know also is that the vaccine alone doesn't have any
efficacy. So if we relied on the nonspecific
interferon induced by the vaccine to have this response, we would see something
with the vaccine alone, and we don't see anything.
So
I'm positive that mRNA vaccine, especially the one we
do in the lab, which is quite dirty, it's not GMP grade like
we would get from Moderna
is inducing an innate immune response.
But in our work at Gementis, it's not involved in the protection just because
the vaccine itself
doesn't work.
Thank you.
Can I just say one thing really quick?
I really liked how you were compartmentalizing the effects of the drug.
We often don't know. AZA could be doing a lot of things.
Yeah.
But you showed that these effects were not through antigen upregulation.
They were through viral mimicry interferon.
And that also on the T cell activation, it wasn't direct demethylation of
interferon gamma. It was also dependent on viral mimicry in that case.
Yeah.
Which is really nice.
Yeah. We tried to look at the antigen expression after azacitidine
because the idea of combining vaccination and azacitidine
before was really for this. The
concept was to vaccinate against a new antigen that were lowly
expressed in tumors.
In the cages.
And because it was actually methylated or silenced.
Mm-hmm.
And trying to force the tumor to express it.
And in our system, we show that this doesn't matter at all.
Right.
Also because we picked antigens that are already expressed at baseline.
But boosting it or not, what really matters is the viral mimicry
effect of azacitidine, which-
Yeah.
-is what interests us.
Thank you.
Okay.
Thank you so much for your attendance.